now let's take a look at the profile
form class in the form package you see
it finds fields display name and t-shirt
size it also defines in amps limit the
t-shirt size because there's only a
certain range of values for t-shirt size
we're going to update the save profile
method in conference API to restrict the
input data to display name and t-shirt
size it's easy to do that simply by
specifying profile form as the input
data argument so here I'm looking at the
save profile method in the conference
API class and you'll see I've passed in
profile form as an argument so now that
we pass the profile form into the save
profile method we need to use it so I've
added the code to get the display name
out of the profile form and also to get
the t-shirt size out of the profile form
for the t-shirt size we only want to set
it if the profile form actually sent it
so we addled the conditional check that
it's not now for the display name I'm
not adding that extra check because
later on we'll be setting a default
display name based on the user's email
but we don't know that just yet now we
can try out our changes